I'm Dean Ronald's my brother a bride
rods and we're in the short to feature
category that short film called the
nether piece of tech industries inc
which was adapted in the future based
incorporated www Susie are you saying
anything at all you know tell us what
was the inspiration behind you know
Bruce telus we were right to feature
with said hey guys there's this contest
he gave us his four page script was like
a three minute thriller challenge I read
it I'm all Hollis just funny and pretty
much he comes from an office environment
and we all pay for an office environment
like working in the cubicle 95 nose to
the grindstone so he hadn't thought it
would be funny if he kind of made a lot
of metaphor you know me more vampires
its exact then to the next level of
actually being vampires have been
working for corporation and kind of push
the two together that's that's kind of
what
hominy about vampires how did you raise
the money for the feature short
habitation I'm glad you asked that
question how we raise money for another
pass incorporated is you know at the
time out loud they do it anyone McDonald
has these monopolies contest and we went
to every monopoly like the four-state
ratings and we collected enough money
scratch their little fingers on to make
we found it best he's kidding we use the
brush short films which is why the
festival's like mr. so awesome we use
our short film helped his platforming do
you know expanding it
kind of help people see the idea for
Canisius made and they can make an
affordable way to translate your toes be
with her film get people to believe in
that idea and then they have something
that they could point to when they're
you know saying what some would even
beat with what's it going to look like
you get it up you believe of that idea
that story and we did festival the
festival able to you know put the money
together so it's great but it's tricky
and put you out to be the best source of
promotion I don't know the best source
of promotion to ourselves and when
you're living in an indie world of all
you have is yourself the computer and
your phone as long as you have that you
know what you can get the word out yeah
you know it is really nobody else is
going to be as passionate about to
explaining your project as the
filmmakers and reminders themselves you
know so really taking the meetings and
you know representing ourselves
individually pretty much helps people
share the enthusiastic see your
enthusiasm what you're doing and they
understand nobody wants to give their
money to someone who's not passionate
about it and you know that's everything
to them so when they can see that
directly from the guys who they're going
to be giving the money to it kind of
gives you a little bit more peace of
mind you know so